[Music]
on this Wednesday night fears of another
flare-up some Alberta Farmers fight to
protect what's left of their property
we've lost our entire Farm
all our livestock our whole life
controversial changes are waiting in the
wings for Canadian passports why is he
deleting our vac
plus how it'll be easier to renew your
passport
a rookie Republican Congressman charged
his Litany of alleged lies and the
potential repercussions for his party
and no way to no more may this makes no
sense busting myths about this month's
movement to keep your grasp growing
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
fire ravaged Alberta is bracing for more
extreme conditions hot dry weather is
threatening to Fan the Flames of
wildfires burning across the province in
some areas temperatures are expected to
hit 30 degrees in the coming days there
are still more than 70 active wildfires
burning across Alberta 24 of them are
out of control one is threatening the
town of Drayton Valley now estimated to
be about 3 500 hectares
so far this year we've had 421 wildfires
burning 410
000 hectares
for context that's about double the
average area burned for the entire
Wildfire season and it's only May 10th
our Heather urac's West is just outside
Drayton Valley where the Flames have
destroyed at least four homes
I actually haven't even looked I I've
stayed away because I don't think that I
can do it Tracy McDonald has been trying
to stay strong it's hard to look at for
days she and her partner Adam Norris
tried to protect their farm from the
Bush Creek Wildfire but the Flames
returned again and again we've lost our
entire Farm all our livestock our whole
life the first time the property caught
fire it was quickly brought under
control the couple fled but believed
their pigs and chickens would be okay we
felt kind of confident that they were
they were fairly safe and then when the
wind changed directions it took time
and then that night their house got fire
as well there was no fire department
that had came for that I know they were
busy with wildfires all across neighbors
over there lost houses as well
[Music]
since then McDonald and Norris have been
too afraid to leave worrying about what
the hot weather will mean for the area
in the days ahead we're very concerned
we're very concerned that it's going to
light up in that Forest again McDonald's
property is inside the evacuation area
that includes the town of Drayton Valley
that's more than 7 200 residents who are
still waiting to find out when they'll
be able to return home
it's been almost a week since the Bush
Creek Fire forced residents to pack
their things and go and while cooler
weather and a bit of rain have helped
with the fire fight Town officials say
it's still too dangerous for people to
return not much left here to burn it's
you know a trailer it might come through
the front trees or something but none
more concerned my neighbors
my neighbors are are in trouble as well
it's why after suffering so many losses
McDonald and her partner plan to stay
right here protecting what they have
left Heather urich's West Global News
near Drayton Valley Alberta
after Canadians faced long lines when
renewing passports the federal
government has announced long-awaited
plans to take that procedure online the
change is set to start in the fall and
is aimed at reducing the months-long
wait times many faced last year but
after today's announcement controversy
quickly sparked not over how Canadians
applied for their passports but what
that document would look like when it
arrived Eric Sorensen explains
new passports are coming this year that
will be more secure and can be renewed
online that's the headline but what's
getting all the attention of the new
pictures inside passports are redesigned
every 10 years in part to make them
harder for counterfeiters but the new
ones will eliminate many iconic images
from the past from Nelly McClung and
Terry Fox to the first Spike and
historic figures like Billy Bishop
instead the new passports will show more
generic scenes of Canada's landscape and
people and Wildlife this new design will
not only be more secure and reliable
but I believe it will also continue to
inspire pride in the hearts of those who
carry it might not Inspire everyone
dropping Terry Fox brought this from the
mayor of his hometown the decision
makers should give their head a shake he
posted our country needs more Terry Fox
not less and expunging the Canadian Vimy
War Memorial in France has upset the
Canadian Legion this image represents
sacrifice it represents the sacrifice
that actually led to the very freedoms
that allow us to travel with our
passports around the world today why is
he deleting our veterans from our
history of course politicians could not
resist he's erasing them and with that
he is insulting all of our veterans
suddenly it was all about veterans they
wrapped themselves in the flags and the
symbols anytime they can but in fact
they nickeled and dimed our veterans
they used them for photo ops and that
exchanges over one picture in the
passport there are more than 20 that
will disappear the founding fathers
explorers the mounties the images that
are being extirpated only appeared in
2013 in the passport before that it was
just a series of maple leaves the
minister of citizenship on the defensive
says the new designs are about security
not erasing Canadian history there's no
feedback we received that says people uh
found our history offensive and this was
meant to reflect a different part of
Canada's Heritage in particular our
natural environment and the diversity of
our people and and Wildlife for those
who travel the images are often obscured
by stamps anyway and those who don't
travel may never turn to the blue nose
on page 35.
a year ago passport lineups upset
Canadians because of Staff shortages the
recent public service strike delayed
passports again and now the new design
is distressing some Canadians lately it
seems Canada's primary travel Document
is a passport to controversy Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
the U.S is preparing for a surge of
migrants at its Southern border as the
Biden Administration scraps a coveted
era policy that gave border agents the
power to block and turn back Asylum
Seekers during the pandemic long lines
of migrants have already started
gathering on Mexico's side of the border
the policy known as title 42 expires
Thursday night one minute before
midnight its expected Customs and Border
agents will process and allow migrants
into the U.S border cities until their
status is resolved
at least six people have died and about
a thousand people have been detained in
Pakistan after the arrest of opposition
leader and former prime minister Imran
Khan on corruption charges today
Pakistan's current leader said
protesters will be dealt with using an
iron fist as a Court ruled the former
cricket star can be held by
investigators for eight days as Redmond
Shannon reports Khan is the latest in a
long line of opposition leaders who've
been arrested or imprisoned in Pakistan
two days of Mayhem in a country already
on the brink of financial ruin
supporters of former Pakistani prime
minister Imran Khan faced off with
police and some set fire to buildings
Furious after Khan's dramatic arrest on
corruption charges on Tuesday
there have been large more peaceful
demonstrations around the world too
including in Canada on Wednesday a court
ordered the former Cricket Superstar to
be detained for eight days as part of a
second corruption investigation
this is not an arrest but a state
abduction said his lawyer Khan's party
colleagues say this arrest is simply a
tactic to prevent him from running in
this false elections when this saw the
most popular leader in the country being
dragged by Islam about police there was
a reaction all over the country protest
is their legal constitutional right keep
it peaceful
Khan was ousted as PM last year and
months later survived an assassination
attempt which he blamed on his
replacement Shabazz Sharif
already hundreds have been arrested and
Sharif says an iron fist will be used to
deal with the protests these
demonstrations much larger than when he
was arrested as opposition leader three
years ago Sharif was later acquitted of
money laundering there is a long and
well established
of incarcerating
an analyst farzana Sheikh says it often
comes after a politician has fallen out
with the ever-powerful military just
like Khan has she says some are even
speculating the military is allowing
violence to spread to a point where
some kind of emergency rule may become
necessary Pakistan's military has
forcefully taken power three times since
the 1950s Redmond Shannon Global News
London
foreign
militants in the Gaza Strip have fired
hundreds of rockets at Israel the latest
violence comes a day after Israeli
airstrikes killed at least 16
Palestinians in Gaza Israel's powerful
Iron Dome air defense system intercepted
at least 62 projectiles it's the
heaviest fighting between the two sides
in months leading to concerns about
full-scale war
one day after the Republicans
front-runner for Presidential nominee
was found liable of sexual abuse the GOP
has a new Crisis coming up why
Congressman George Santos has been hit
with criminal charges plus why an
American sportscaster is apologizing to
a Canadian hockey player
and the top dog making history at a
prestigious competition
[Music]
controversial U.S congressman George
Santos was arrested on charges related
to multiple federal crimes including
fraud money laundering and lying to
Congress the New York Republican pleaded
not guilty to the 13-count Federal
indictment and says he's ready to fight
the charges and as Reggie cicchini
explains Hefty ramifications for his
party could also be on the horizon
in this Suburban Long Island courtroom
Congressman George Santos not even four
months on the job was arraigned on 13
charges stemming from a lengthy web of
falsehoods the reality is is I'm sorry
it's a witch hut I'm going to take care
of clearly my name and I look forward to
doing that prosecutors say they're
unraveling lies that took years to
stitch together alleging Santos was
involved in fraudulent schemes and
Brazen misrepresentations the
must be absolutely overwhelming for the
prosecutors to have put this together
this quickly the embattled congressman's
frequent Fabrications have made him
something of a mockery he claimed he
lost his mother during the 9 11 attacks
when in reality she wasn't in the
country Santos also said he came from
Jewish ancestry which was walked back in
a cringe-worthy way they always joked
I'm Catholic but I'm also Jewish
beyond the false facts of his personal
life lie more legally perilous matters
the charges of wire fraud stem from
allegations he accepted covet relief
funds well employed and running for
office and that he embezzled campaign
donations he's also accused of lying to
Congress about his income and wealth
conviction could result in decades in
prison in America there's a presumption
of innocence but there are serious
charges he's going to have to go through
the legal process scrutiny over Santos's
cloud of chaos didn't impact his ability
to win or be sworn in but did result in
a reduced role Santos would never put on
committee so he won't serve on committee
after completing not guilty he was
released on five hundred thousand
dollars Bond meaning he can still report
to work despite colleagues concerns
bottom line is his conduct has been
embarrassing and disgraceful the level
of fraud the level of extremism uh the
the continued you know lies throughout
all of this these are things that you
know we've known Santos is refusing
calls to resign and in fact says he will
run again for re-election resulting in a
growing push to expel but that's
something that party leadership is weary
of because it would trigger a
by-election and it would open up a
possible pickup for Democrats and
further reduce an already razor-thin
Republican majority
in Washington thanks Reggie an ESPN
anchor has apologized for mocking an
indigenous hockey player's name during a
sports center segment
Zach White Cloud kind of name is White
Cloud great Navy or toilet paper John
Anderson who made the comment released a
statement saying he blew it White Cloud
says he accepted the apology after
talking with Anderson in private the Las
Vegas golden knights defenseman is the
first NHL player from Sioux Valley
Dakota nation which is about three hours
West of Winnipeg
[Music]
migrant mercenaries ahead Russia's
attempts to recruit front-line fighters
from Afghanistan
[Music]
to a breakthrough now in bakmud where
Ukrainian troops have pushed back
Russian forces a top Ukrainian Commander
says a Russian Brigade abandoned
positions on the city's Southwestern
outskirts retreating by up to two
kilometers the result of repeated
counter-attacks by Ukraine's resistance
the Eastern Flashpoint City in the
Donetsk region has been a primary target
of moscow's military offensive and has
seen some of the bloodiest ground
battles since the War began as fighting
drags on Russian forces are seeing
massive losses on the battlefield the
U.S estimates as many as one hundred
thousand Kremlin Fighters have been
killed or wounded and it appears Moscow
may be looking for recruits outside its
borders Global News spoke with former
Afghan Special Forces who say their
comrades have taken up arms to fight for
Russia in Ukraine Taria Israel shagufa
Danish report
Afghan special forces were designed to
create Elite homegrown Commandos to
fight the Taliban they were trained by
NATO countries including Canada but
after Afghanistan fell in 2021 these
highly skilled operators found
themselves on Taliban kill lists
targeted for their extraordinary skills
and their history of hunting top Taliban
Commanders
now the former commander of afghan's
Special Forces says Russia is trying to
recruit his troops who fled to fight on
another Front Line the war in Ukraine I
said Ukraine and Russia is not your
country Global News spoke to three
ex-members of the Afghan Special Forces
including Lieutenant General Mohamed
Fareed Ahmadi they allege Russia through
intermediaries in Iran is trying to lure
Afghans to the war in Ukraine they are
receiving offers and some of them
already gone and most of them rejected
this recruitment letter circulating on
social media promises a monthly salary
of fifteen hundred dollars U.S from the
moment they enter Russia and a Russian
Federation passport it can be a hard
offer to Turn Down for former Afghan
Special Forces members living in Iran
illegally like this man Global News is
protecting his identity because of the
threat of deportation
my friend who was another former Special
Forces member went to fight for Russia
two months ago we haven't heard from him
since
the
situation is harsh in Iran but if my
family and I returned to Afghanistan we
will be killed that's why I'm
considering fighting for Russia so is
another former Afghan Special Forces
member who spoke to Global News and
asked to remain anonymous
it's better to fight for Russia than let
my family starve
with the conflict in Ukraine dragging
into its second year Moscow is desperate
for soldiers the Kremlin is relying on
Mercenaries like the Wagner group and
releasing convicts to take up arms right
now the the popularity for the war is
domestically is starting to decline a
British intelligence report says Russian
military recruiters are targeting
Central Asian migrant workers in Russia
to serve in Ukraine at mosques and
immigration offices the Ukrainian
Canadian Congress says it's another sign
the Russian armed forces are running out
of people willing to fight Russia is
trying to exploit
poverty in other parts of the world when
asked by global news about the
allegations the Russian Embassy said it
had no information on this topic the
former Afghan Special Forces members we
spoke to say they don't want to fight
for Russian forces but say they feel
abandoned by Western governments
including Canada the Canadian government
will not allow Afghan Special Forces to
come here as part of ottawa's refugee
pledge so the former soldiers are
running out of options
Taria esri Global News Ottawa
[Music]
to grow or not to grow next why experts
say no mo may makes no sense
[Music]
best in show tonight is the pvgv
Buddy Holly a petite basay Griffon Von
Deon won the top prize at the
Westminster dog show last night it's the
first time the breed has ever won in the
events 147 year history he had some
tough competition though beating out six
other finalists rummy the Pekinese was
aiming to bring home the third trophy in
11 years for his breed and you may
remember Winston the French Bulldog that
came so close last year when he came in
second always the bridesmaid
proper grooming is a big part of being
Best in Show but there's a new movement
to keep things a little more wild when
it comes to your lawn it's called no Mom
May the idea is not to cut your grass
before June 1st and that allowing spring
flowers and weeds to grow will help bees
to pollinate but is that true Mike
drolet finds out
spring has sprung when the first
pollinating happy bees start buzzing
around yet the wildflowers they crave
are still scarce and that's how Nomo May
was born now how don't cut the
wildflowers bloomed into don't cut your
grass is the question no one may is
certainly catching on you're seeing
municipalities all over signing up for
it nomome
well in theory it sounds like a great
idea but here's the catch nobody thought
to ask the experts the people who study
the science of grass what they thought
so we took our questions to Guelph
Ontario and the turf grass Institute
home to the foremost experts on grass in
the country and I just thought about it
for a little bit and I thought this
makes no sense
um it didn't take you long to think
about it no it makes no sense it it's
not something we should be doing
particularly in Ontario and in most
places in Canada why well for starters
rodents fleas and ticks thrive in Long
Grass
and without flowers there was no pollen
anyway and no dandelions aren't worth
saving it doesn't have very high
nutrition pollen and also if it wasn't
tolerant to mowing we wouldn't have them
in lawns you can moat in Lions
as for the science of Lawns the shade
from longer grass or excessive trimmings
Left Behind prevent New Growth creating
room for more weeds I don't think this
would ever take hold because what will
happen is people learn what happens when
you don't mow in May the people who do
it will end up not having Lawns except
the ever catchy Nomo May is taking hold
despite an easy solution from the grass
experts encourage people to plant
wildflowers what's your catchphrase
#plantnatives or hashtag Mo as needed
right you need to work on that it
doesn't really roll off the tongue
science rarely does microlay global news
at Guelph Ontario
and that is global national for this
Wednesday night I'm nitu Garcia tonight
your Canada is Brodeur Lake in Cape
Breton Nova Scotia thanks so much for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
thank you